[Musik]
seit 1949 ringen politiker im deutschen
bundestag um entscheidungen richtig
mehr als sieben jahrzehnte
nachkriegsgeschichte voller kontroverser
und leidenschaftlicher wortgefechte
debatten zugesandten fragen bei denen
die parteigrenzen häufig verschwimmen
seit der damals immerhin schon ja gesagt
aber sie nicht jeder abgeordnete ist
frei mir muss keiner meine abstimmung
freigeben aber normalerweise entscheiden
wir nach fraktionen ich sage die
wahrheit und wenn ich mich irre sage ich
das auch und die lasse ich mir von ihnen
nicht kaputt machen
wir wollen endlich ruhe und frieden und
da gibt es unterschiedliche meinungen
aber heute muss man daran zweifel das
ist die voraussetzung warum sie hier
sitzen
deutschlands wiederbewaffnung und das
tauziehen um hartz 4 kriegseinsätze am
hindukusch und der streit um die
sterbehilfe oder die rettung des euro
konflikte bei denen die parteitreue mit
dem gewissen kollidiert niemand wird
natürlich offen sagen dass ein
abgeordneter von der fraktionsführung
erpresst wird und zugleich weiß jeder
worum es geht und was auf dem spiel
steht
erpressung kann überzeugungen nicht
ersetzen ein erpresst das ergebnis ist
ein verlogenes ergebnis
wenn volksvertreter nicht ihrem
parteibuch sondern der eigenen
überzeugung folgen wird es auch schon
mal frostig in den fraktionen
politischer ungehorsam hat seinen preis
da hat man abgeordneten angedroht dass
sie ihren listenplatz verlieren dass sie
nicht mehr in den bundestag zurückkehren
werden da wird mit ganz harten bandagen
gekämpft
schröder hatten nie direkt gedruckt auch
seine laufburschen sie soll man zu hören
ich habe ihn klar gesagt wo es geht
genau diese konflikte aber gipfelten oft
in debatten die unvergesslich worden
weil sie bundestags geschichte schrieben
und viele von ihnen wurden zu
sternstunden des deutschen parlaments
[Applaus]
die mauer fällt eine grenze verschwindet
ost und west werden wieder vereint doch
nur zwei jahre nach den jubelfeiern geht
erneut ein riss durchs land diesmal in
der hauptstadt frage
das tauziehen um den standort der
gesamtdeutschen regierung bestimmt als
wäre das zukunfts entscheid im
hintergrund stand die debatte was soll
das für in deutschland seien rückkehr
des nationalstaats das war
unausgesprochen das thema dieser debatte
soll berlin wieder hauptstadt und
regierungssitz werden die metropole
steht für den aufstieg und fall des
dritten reichs die teilung blockade den
mauerbau
berlin ist das symbol der jüngeren
deutschen geschichte und einer
unheilvollen vergangenheit oder bleibt
das parlament in bonn
die beschauliche stadt am rhein ist nach
dem krieg zum politischen zentrum
deutschlands gewachsen
41 jahre lang war sie hauptstadt soll
das alles vorbei sein soll bald zu einer
provinzstadt verkommen sogar das
parlament selbst ist 1991 in der
hauptstadt frage zerstritten
selbst innerhalb der parteien lässt sich
keinen konsens herstellen
also ich bin schon dafür dass eine
fraktion sich mühe gibt mit einer stimme
zu sprechen damit der wähler weiß wen er
gewählt hat
die erwartung ist dass die minderheit
sich dem mehrheit anschließt
denn nur als gruppe so ist die erfahrung
kann man gemeinsam kann man sozusagen
politisch etwas erreichen und auch
diesmal ist alles anders
sogar die bundesregierung ist in ihren
ansichten gespalten die
fraktionsdisziplin scheint außer kraft
wir halten den parlamentssitz für das
herzstück einer wirklichen hauptstadt
deshalb sollte der bundestag seinen sitz
in berlin nehmen erst dann ist berlin
wirklich die hauptstadt deutschlands
wie jeder möglichst jeder wollte sich zu
diesem doch auch emotional so umkämpften
thema äußern
es gehörte noch nie zur politik dieser
republik dass man einen struktur publik
in allen regionen durch das schaffen
eines struktur problems in einer anderen
region lösen wollte
meine antwort ist ich stimme für berlin
die stimme für berlin
lasst den kleinen bahnen parlament und
regierung und verliert mit bundestag und
regierung viel berlin gewinnt mit
bundestag und regierung viel neue
probleme ich fahr der sprecher der
bonner ich war nicht in hochform
dabei hatte ich so gute argumente aber
ich hatte im hinterkopf ein argument das
ich nicht so auswischen konto nämlich
das argument wir haben immer versprochen
berlin wird die hauptstadt des
wiedervereinigten deutschlands hätte
mich spontan entschieden überhaupt zu
reden und deshalb gewinnt in dieser
entscheidung die tatsache für mich
bedeutung dass in 40 jahren niemand
zweifel hatte dass bei der einheit
deutschlands parlament und regierung
ihren sitz wieder in berlin haben werden
die hauptstadt debatte war eine
sternstunde des parlamentarismus weil
hier tatsächlich die freie rede vor
allen dingen die rede von wolfgang
schäuble im parlament überzeugungskraft
entfaltet hat und es ergebnis
unmittelbar beeinflusst hat dann haben
glaube ich alle auch gemerkt wir können
hier nicht 25 30 jahre sagen berlin ist
unsere hauptstadt und wir müssen alles
über elly tun und wenn es dann auf den
punkt kommt dann sagen wir bleiben in
bonn
und deswegen bitte ich sie herzlich
stimmen sie mit mir für berlin wäre ich
nicht im rollstuhl gesessen und hätte
ich nicht so erbarmungswürdig ausgesehen
den zwar relativ bald nachdem ich nach
dem 1 1 ein kranker mensch auf mich
geschossen hatte und ich saß schon
wirklich als ich die bilder seht tue ich
mir selber noch leidlich mir dreckig
gegen und weil zugreifen das hat
natürlich der rede noch einmal eine
gewisse wirkung gegeben
bis in den späten abend des 20 juni 1991
ergreifen über 300 redner das wort
es gab auch einzelnen die hatten dann
schon sehr dem alkohol zugesprochen weil
die debatte über stunden lief und dabei
und ein casino du musst ja irgendwas
machen ich dran bist insofern war das
eigentlich eine ganz muntere debatte vor
der abstimmung steht fest es wird knapp
doch berlin steigt in dieser nacht zur
neuen hauptstadt deutschlands auf mit
einer mehrheit von nur 18 stimmen
ausgelassene jubel auf den straßen
berlins aber die begeisterung erfasst
nicht das ganze land nach der abstimmung
stand ich auf dem bahnhof in bonn und
warte darauf hinzu kommt eine ältere
dame ging erstmal ein bisschen um mich
herum und dann trat sie auf mich zu und
sagte sie sind doch hier sage ich ja was
sie uns angetan haben mit dieser
entscheidung aber wäre die entscheidung
anders ausgegangen
wer sie immer wieder in frage gestellt
worden
in bonn hat das nachkriegs parlament im
herbst 1949 seine arbeit aufgenommen und
sich seine oberste maxime ins
grundgesetz geschrieben
die volksvertreter repräsentieren die
politischen parteien aber sie folgen in
ihrem urteil allein den eigenen
überzeugungen
das ist eine so wichtige prämisse in
unserem grundgesetz dass man das gar
nicht hoch genug fahren
der einzelne abgeordnete entscheidet ob
und wann er von diesem verfassungsrecht
gebrauch macht und möglicherweise anders
stimmt als die mehrheit seiner fraktion
damit hat die verfassung der politik
einen ehrenhaften rahmen gesteckt aber
der parlamentarische alltag gehorcht
häufig anderen gesetzen
ich glaube dass es immer ein
spannungsfeld ich glaube in abgeordnete
sind immer erst mal auf zeit gewählt und
müssen in dieser zeit schauen dass sie
ihre vorstellungen verwirklichen
natürlich sei abgehauen seinem gewissen
verpflichtet jeder abgeordnete kann im
parlament so entscheiden wie er ist aber
er ist naturgemäß in sachzwängen
1961 regelt die ddr innerhalb berlins
alle grenzübergänge ab wenige tage
später tritt der bundestag in bonn zu
einer sondersitzung zusammen
wie will die brd mit dem neuen staat im
osten deutschlands künftig umgehen einem
land dass deutsche bürger hinter
stacheldraht einsperrt
1969 wird willy brandt kanzler einer
sozial-liberalen koalition und bemüht
sich um ein nachbarschaftliches
verhältnis zur ddr
doch die diskussion um die ostverträge
stellt das bonner parlament schnell vor
eine zerreißprobe
also ich kam bundestag und es war sofort
rabatt samba nämlich grundlagenvertrag
ja oder nein
die cdu sieht in der anerkennung der
ostgrenzen das nach dem krieg gemeinsam
formulierte ziel gefährdet eine
wiedervereinigung des geteilten
deutschlands aber nicht alle
abgeordneten folgen der parteilinie
ich war eine von den vieren die dem
grundlagenvertrag zugestimmt haben
also von den vieren aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion ich war schon ein
bisschen baba man hat sich nicht sogar
mit mir gesehen es ist so schlimm als
händisch lepra fleisch nicht aber so
kurz vor lepra weiß schon
die mehrheit der opposition fürchtet mit
der annäherung an den osten den
ausverkauf gesamtdeutscher interessen
gesellschafter aufgehört emotionales war
ja als ging es um kreuzzüge und das war
natürlich eine fraktion auch so eine
fraktion erträgt abweichler nicht so
gerne
und schon gar nicht in einer solchen
frage die eigentlich die kernfrage der
damaligen zeit war pfingsten 1972 ein
besuchstag in ost berlin führt menschen
für einige stunden wieder zusammen
bis dahin ring das parlament jahre lang
um einen gemeinsamen standpunkt bis zum
gescheiterten misstrauensvotum gegen
kanzler willy brandt die ostgebiete
waren für viele eine frage der heimat
und eine frage der identität
deutschlands
1999 stürzt der blutige konflikt im
kosovo den bundestag in ein dilemma seit
sieben jahren toben in den ländern des
ehemaligen jugoslawien erbitterte
kriegel sollen dort deutsche soldaten an
der seite der nato eingreifen
die deutschen waren pazifistischen die
sonne nach zwei weltkriegen
deswegen war das besonders schwer zum
ersten mal wieder die bundeswehr in
einen bewaffneten einsatz zu zwingen sei
es im kosovo sei später in afghanistan
darüber sind parteien beinahe zerbrochen
bisher beteiligte sich deutschland nur
an friedensmissionen aber jetzt steht
die bundeswehr im kampfeinsatz vom
bundestag beschlossen in den letzten
tagen der ära kohl in der nachfolge
regierung schröder gerät nun der grüne
koalitionspartner unter druck vor allem
der linke flügel der ehemaligen
friedenspartei lehnt die beteiligung an
den luftschlägen ab
joschka fischer sagte das ist ja
praktisch alles voran aber wir haben
auschwitz im hintergrund und wir
enthalten uns jetzt um möglicherweise
ein land zu befreien
das waren auch wort keulen die da
benutzt wurden der interne streit der
grünen eskaliert mit einem farbbeutel
anschlag außenminister fischer der
energisch für den kosovo einsatz wirkt
schließlich steht die koalition auf dem
spiel
nie wieder auschwitz nie wieder
völkermarkt nie wieder faschismus beides
gehört bei mir zusammen
liebe freundinnen und freunde die grünen
hatten traditionell die
auseinandersetzung zwischen realer und
fundis aber die wurde bis dahin nicht
mit gewalt ausgetragen
aus diesen gründen lehne ich zwar den
antrag der bundesregierung nicht ab aber
ich kann ihm auch nicht zustimmen ich
werde mich wie einige andere kollegen
aus der bündnisgrünen fraktion enthalten
schließlich ringen sich die zweifler
durch das rot grüne bündnis wird
gerettet
doch die harmonie ist nicht von dauer
nach dem 11 september 2001 bringt der
amerikanische anti terror einsatz in
afghanistan
die koalition erneut ins wanken etliche
abgeordnete beider parteien stellen sich
offen gegen eine deutsche beteiligung
die regierungsmehrheit steht auf der
kippe
da hat der damalige bundeskanzler
schröder was ganz gemein ist und meiner
ansicht nach auch verfassungswidriges
gemacht er hat die frage bist du für
oder gegen den kriegseinsatz verbunden
mit der vertrauensfrage
es ist die schärfste waffe die das
deutsche grundgesetz einem
regierungschef gibt gerhard schröder
riskiert neuwahlen und damit den eigenen
sturz aber er sieht keinen anderen
ausweg als diese machtprobe
der bundeskanzler kann seinem amt und
kann seiner verantwortung für das
gemeinwohl nur dann entsprechen wenn sie
eine person und wenn sein programm das
vertrauen und die zustimmung der ihn
tragenden mitglieder des hohen hauses
finden
er musste befürchten dass seine
koalition aus spd und grünen eben nicht
dem beschluss fassen werde und er wollte
natürlich nicht dass ein beschluss
gefasst wird wo er sich auch cdu csu und
fdp stützen musste deswegen die
vertrauensfrage gestellt er hat damit
deutlich gemacht dass hier die außen-
und sicherheitspolitische
handlungsfähigkeit der bundesrepublik
zur debatte steht und nicht nur die
einzelne entscheidung über einen
einzelnen einsatz
für den juniorpartner ein dilemma werden
die grünen um jeden preis die
regierungsbeteiligung retten dann sage
ich ihnen ist das wirklich der blanken
opportunismus ein bisschen mandat ein
bisschen regierungsbeteiligung ist mir
wichtiger als die frage von krieg und
frieden und das zerstört vertrauen
dieses parlament und auch in diese
koalition
der grüne koalitionspartner weiß was auf
dem spiel steht
außenminister fischer kämpft um die
zustimmung seiner partei
und ich wäre dafür für die politik
dieser bundesregierung bei der
vertrauensfrage
als jemand der einer partei angehört die
sie mit dieser entscheidung immer schwer
getan hat ich werbe hier um die
zustimmung gerade jene und ich habe den
letzten tagen erlebt wie schwer es auch
persönlich ist ich werbe um die
zustimmung jener weil ich ihre
grundhaltung 8
das ist kein opportunist fischer
pazifismus ohne sind ehrlicher
überzeugung bis zum schluss aber gibt es
in der grünen fraktion noch 14
abweichlern
dann wurde zu einem kleinen trick
gegriffen und dann haben die 14 gesagt
gut die hälfte von uns wird vertretend
für die anderen dagegen stimmen und die
andere hälfte stimmt dafür um klar zu
machen wir wollen die regierung nicht in
frage stellen
das ist auf eine für grüne sehr
eigenartige weise ausgegangen weil am
schluss durften die männer alle dagegen
stimmen die frauen mussten ganz
ordentlich dafür stimmen und haben dann
natürlich erklärt warum sie das so
gemacht haben
bei der abstimmung am 16 november 2001
schließlich geht die rechnung auf wenn
auch haarscharf mit nur zwei stimmen
über der erforderlichen mehrheit wird
die bundeswehr nach afghanistan
geschickt schröders vertrauensfrage
zielte auf die eigenen leute ab die vom
kurs der koalition ab welchen ein
heikles druckmittel
denn die fraktionsdisziplin verbietet
das grundgesetz zwar nicht wohl aber
ausdrücklich den zwang
die frage ist ist das demokratie wenn
eine ganze fraktion auf eine linie
getrimmt wird auch wenn die abgeordneten
das vielleicht anders sehen wenn ein
abgeordneter nicht so stimmen will wie
es die fraktionen beschlossen dass die
fraktions haltung ist dann soll das der
fraktionsgeschäftsführer mitteilen
einfach dass sie wissen dass sie nicht
völlig überrascht werden nicht mehr aber
und zwang gibt es nicht und jeder ist
frei schon anfang der 1950 er jahre
bewegt deutschlands militärische zukunft
die gemüter soll sich das land wieder
bewaffnen und streitkräfte aufbauen
dürfen so kurz nach den gräueln des
zweiten weltkriegs und natürlich ging es
auch um die frage ob man mit den leuten
die von der wehrmacht noch übrig waren
eine demokratische armee aufbauen kann
die offiziere haben alle gedient andere
offiziere hatte man nicht also erfand
man das konzept des bürgers in uniform
einer armee die demokratisch ans
parlament gebunden ist nicht an die
regierung
die usa drängen auf einen deutschen
verteidigungs beitrag gegen die sowjets
bundeskanzler konrad adenauer und seine
schwarz-gelbe koalition fordern die
aufrüstung gegen die wie es heißt
aggressive expansionspolitik russlands
wir wollen wirklich ruhe und frieden
wurden drei und den angriff aus dem die
spd hingegen lehnt die wiederbewaffnung
kategorisch ab die opposition im
bundestag will die kosten für eine armee
lieber in soziale aufgaben investiert
sehen
[Musik]
ganz anders macht die spd auch weite
teile der bevölkerung stehen den
regierungsplänen kritisch gegenüber
viele menschen tragen ihren protest im
frühjahr 52 auf die straßen
schließlich musste die polizei trotz des
nasskalten tages die straßen mit hilfe
ihrer wasserspritzen freihalten
mein großvater ist aus der cdu
ausgetreten wegen der wiederbewaffnung
weil ihnen der krieg so traumatisiert
und geprägt hatte
dass er der meinung war dass deutsche
nie wieder waffen in die hand nehmen
dürfen
zwei tage lang debattiert der bundestag
hoch emotional über den deutschen
beitritt in ein westliches
verteidigungsbündnis mitten in der nacht
des 8 februar 1952 fällt die
entscheidung
die leidenschaftlich umkämpfte
gesetzesvorlage wurde mit den stimmen
der regierungskoalition in den frühen
morgenstunden angenommen
1955 schlägt die geburtsstunde der
bundeswehr
die ersten rekruten werden vereidigt
fast 30 jahre später 300.000 menschen
demonstrieren 1981 im bonner hofgarten
gegen das wettrüsten der supermächte und
die gefahr eines atomkrieges
ihr protest richtet sich vor allem gegen
den nato doppelbeschluss der westlichen
verteidigungsgemeinschaft wobei man
nicht vergessen darf dass dieses
nato-bündnis ja deswegen zustande kamen
mit westdeutschland
das hieß immer so schön to keep the
russians american sign and the germans
da also die russen raushalten aus dem
nato-bündnis und dem gebiet die
amerikaner in europa festhalten und die
deutschen deckeln damit sie nicht wieder
blödsinn machen falls die sowjetunion
ihre auf westeuropa gerichteten
mittelstreckenraketen nicht abbaut will
die usa vergleichbare nuklearwaffen in
europa stationieren
bundeskanzler helmut schmidt ist von
dieser strategie überzeugt anders als
seine regierung viele in der
sozialliberalen koalition verweigerten
die gefolgschaft
ein besonders einschlägiger nachweis
dafür dass die unabhängigkeit von
abgeordneten die in unserer verfassung
belegt und beschworen wird keineswegs
nur auf dem papier steht sondern gelebte
praxis ist
der widerstand gegen schmidt eskaliert
außenminister genscher und drei weitere
fdp minister treten zurück
sie bereiten einen koalitionswechsel mit
der cdu vor
die bundestagssitzung am ersten oktober
1982 geht in die geschichte ein
das parlament entzieht dem bundeskanzler
das vertrauen eine knappe mehrheit von
sieben stimmen beendet die ära schmidt
helmut kohl wird neuer bundeskanzler und
setzte den nato doppelbeschluss durch
doch noch immer ist die
bevölkerungsmehrheit gegen die
aufrüstung die proteste nehmen
historische dimensionen an
im oktober 1983 demonstrieren allein in
bonn
500.000 menschen der neue kanzler
erkennt er darf nichts überstürzen
helmut kohl hat sich damals mit dem
hubschrauber über den hofgarten fliegen
lassen um zu sehen wie viele menschen
sind wirklich daran tief beeindruckt und
es gibt offensichtlich eine überlegung
bei ihm selber zu dem zeitpunkt vor der
stationierung dem amerikanischen
präsidenten bush zu schreiben stop lasst
uns das nochmal überlegen wir müssen
widerstand ist mir zu groß kurz darauf
bricht die sowjetunion die verhandlungen
mit dem westen ab und die usa beginnen
mit der stationierung von pershing zwei
raketen in deutschland dass gerade eine
politische premiere erlebt hat zum
ersten mal in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik wurde nun ein kanzler
weil er seine mehrheit verloren hatte
durch ein konstruktives misstrauensvotum
gestürzt insofern steht dahinter auch
ein wandel im verständnis der
parlamentarischen demokratie der
bundesrepublik
mehr als fünf millionen arbeitslose
geringes wachstum und zu hohe
staatsschulden 2003 zieht gerhard
schröder ein rezept aus dem hut das
sogar treue sozialdemokraten entsetzt
die agenda 2010 werden meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren leistungen
des staates kürzen eigenverantwortung
fördern und mehr eigenleistung von jedem
einzelnen abfordern müssen alle kräfte
der gesellschaft werden ihren beitrag
leisten müssen unternehmer und
arbeitnehmer freiberuflich tätige und
der rentner die agenda 2010 war die ganz
große zerreißprobe für die spd die sie
übrigens hinterher nie wieder überwunden
hat damit kommen sie nicht durch die
probleme holen sie ein mit hearts 3 und
hartz4 wird es nicht weniger arbeitslose
geben sondern mehr arme arbeitslose
das problem liegt ganz schlicht
ergreifend darin dass sie in diesem
gesetz nichts tun um den markt für neue
arbeitsplätze zu erweitern
gewerkschaften und sozialverbände
fürchten massiven sozialabbau und die
spaltung der gesellschaft
daneben drückt und jetzt wollen wir uns
alles wegnehmen wurde gegen alle
widerstände will schröder seiner agenda
durchsetzen
als selbst in der eigenen partei die
zweifler zu nehmen droht der kanzler
schließlich sogar mit rücktritt
[Musik]
das heißt es wird alles mit allem
verknüpft und das ist immer sehr
problematisch bis hin zu der basta
politik mit der schröder leider dann
auch bekannt wurde
nach dem motto dann geh ich halt
minijobs die ausweitung der leiharbeit
und die sogenannten ich-ags hat der
spd-chef bereits durchsetzen können
ins kreuzfeuer aber gerät nun vor allem
sein vorhaben namens hartz iv die
zusammenlegung von arbeitslosen und
sozialhilfe
kritiker aus dem linken parteiflügel
starten ein mitgliederbegehren sie
halten die folgen für noch nicht
ausreichend diskutiert
zuerst lese ich ob das
versicherungsverträge oder gesetze sind
das kleingedruckte und danach entscheide
ich ernst genommen und wurde man erst
als man zur offenen rebellion aufrief
dann ging das natürlich nach dem motto
da kommen irgendwelche leute an und
fallenden kanzlerin den rücken seiner
fraktion war das natürlich ein problem
weil die mehrheitsverhältnisse im
bundesrat so eng waren wenn der zehn
fehlten und es waren zwölf die gesagt
haben wir machen da nicht mit
da wusste man da gibt es keine mehrheit
der innerparteiliche widerstand kann
schröder gefährlich werden
die spd oberen versuchen die abtrünnigen
zu bekehren
um den kanzler nicht zu beschädigen
das land dann immer die situation bei
denen man intensiv mit denen sprechen
musste und natürlich haben sie ihren im
wahlkreis auch nochmal rückversichert
also das hat schon heftige gespräche
gehen und auch viel sorgen ausgelöst
könnte das ganze scheitern
bis dann hin zu einzelgesprächen und
dann noch anderen drucksituationen die
in den wahlkreis hineinreichen oder du
kommst nicht mehr auf die landesliste
für leute die keinen eigenen wahlkreis
haben gibt es riesige druckmittel
und das da gibt es eine große palette
aber damals hat schon ausgereicht das
sozusagen die ganze regierung da aufs
spiel gesetzt wurde
mir ist klar gesagt worden dass ich nun
auf meinem sitz im parteivorstand
verzichten könnte dies ist auch passiert
schröder hat nie direkt gedruckt wird er
auch seine laufbahn
aber es war deutlich wer widerspricht
fliegt aus die dunkle seite des
bundestages so mancher parlamentarier
hat sie erlebt quer durch die parteien
wer zu hartnäckig auf seine überzeugung
pocht stört den fraktions frieden
was die mütter und väter des
grundgesetzes nicht bedachten parteien
funktionieren im ernstfall wie jede
irakische struktur
wer sich nicht an weisungen von oben
hält verbaut sich womöglich die zukunft
das kann mir passieren du hast doch
damals gegen uns gestimmt dort sieht der
stimme enthalten
und jetzt willst du jeweils werden dass
mit dem druck und mit den drogen das tut
mir leid ist ein bisschen übertrieben es
mag das auch mal im einzelfall geben mag
es gibt ja wird wie dummes zeug geredet
der tagelang aber ich akzeptiere und ich
habe es auch nie so erlebt
niemand wird natürlich offen sagen dass
ein abgeordneter von der
fraktionsführung erpresst wird und
zugleich weiß jeder worum es geht und
was auf dem spiel steht
also diese mechanismen sind schon das
ist nicht im vergnügungsausschuss schon
froh wenn der arzt im bett bist doch
einigermaßen heil schröders kritiker
aber lassen sich schließlich zählen die
rot grüne koalition setzt das
umstrittene reform paket am 17 oktober
2003 durch mit einer knappen mehrheit
von zehn stimmen
fünf jahre zuvor hat der bundestag die
einführung des euro beschlossen
in keinem anderen land ist die neue
währung damals so umstritten
die debatte im plenum dagegen mag als
sternstunde gelten selten herrschte
zwischen und innerhalb der fraktionen so
viel harmonie oder mitte dieses
jahrhunderts gilt auch dass das
europäische einigung der glücksfall der
geschichte ist für uns in europa und vor
allem für uns deutsche mit diesem
schritt den der deutsche bundestag heute
mit großer mehrheit beschließen wird
wird der integrationsprozess der
europäische integrationsprozess eine
neue qualität erreichen
der eintritt in die währungsunion mit
den vorgeschlagenen elf mitgliedstaaten
ist stabilitäts politisch vertretbar
mehr lohn
es ist der richtige schritt zum
richtigen zeitpunkt die währungsunion
ist die brücke zum einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert aber meine damen und herren
es macht nicht nur sinn
bei dieser in der tat historischen
entscheidung über die chancen zu reden
sondern man darf auch die probleme die
damit verbunden sind nicht verschweigen
auch viele ökonomen und die linke damals
noch pds warnen vor unkalkulierbaren
gefahren
man kann ein kontinent nicht über geld
einen das hat noch nie in der geschichte
funktioniert und das wird auch hier
nicht funktionieren
im endeffekt alle mitgetragen aber unter
großen bauchschmerzen und und den wenn
man so will verdauungs vorgängen jene
aber auch schmerzen daten wir bis heute
in ganz europa wird die einführung des
euro als epochale ereignis gefeiert
tatsächlich jedoch entwickelt sich die
gemeinschaftswährung bald zum
problemfall
spätestens mit dem alarmruf aus
griechenland jagd ab 2010 ein
krisengipfel in brüssel den nächsten
auch der bundestag debattiert in
zahllosen sitzungen notfallpläne eisern
gibt die kanzlerin die parole vor europa
scheitert wenn der euro scheitert europa
gewinnt der euro gewinnt
viele bürger verstehen die
rettungsmechanismen und pakete kaum noch
geschweige denn ihre kryptischen namen
fsme fsf esm fiskal pakt über deutlich
aber ist die probleme der währungsunion
in europa wurden unterschätzt haben die
banken versagt haben die staaten zur
rettungsaktion getrieben haben die
weltwirtschaft sozusagen in einen tiefen
abgrund gezogen da mussten wir
konjunkturpakete machen mit den
konjunkturpaketen haben wir uns
verschuldet jetzt haben wir die schulden
will jetzt wird gegen die schulden der
staaten spekuliert die linken sehen ihre
bedenken gegen den euro bestätigt und
attestieren nun auch dem vorgehen zu
seiner rettung kapitale fehler
wir brauchen die unabhängigkeit der
staaten von der privatbank sonst führen
die sie länger durchs land und zwar sie
alle vier zusammen
aber die immer neuen milliardenschweren
rettungsschirme bringen selbst in der
regierung zweifler hervor
hatte man den bürgern nicht versprochen
dass kein staat für die schulden des
anderen haftet da gab es ja auch
kritiker herr bosbach zum beispiel und
dann der damalige bundeskanzler amtschef
pofalla hat gesagt ich kann deine fresse
nicht mehr sehen also so tief ging das
schon im grunde roland pofalla bei dem
zusammenprall nur das gesagt was ohnehin
im kanzleramt gedacht wurde und es gab
nicht wenige die gesagt haben
in der sache hast du ja völlig recht
aber wir können doch jetzt nicht anders
stimmen wenn die eu-staaten sich so
verabredet haben zu einer historisch
einmaligen situation kommt es am 29
september 2011
weil zwei abgeordnete der cdu und fdp
von der parteilinie abweichen wollen
ihre fraktionen sie nicht im plenum
reden lassen
bundestagspräsident norbert lammert
schreibt an diesem tag ein stück
parlamentsgeschichte er gibt den beiden
abweichlern jeweils fünf minuten
sprechzeit sie machen von dem rederecht
gebrauch dass sie als mitglied des
deutschen bundestages selbstverständlich
haben mit und ohne zugehörigkeit und
zuordnung zur jeweiligen fraktion und
ich denke es entspricht sowohl unserem
selbstverständnis wie der völlig
unmissverständliche verfassungslage dass
wir diesem anspruch rechnung tragen
lammertz verhalten gegenüber den
abweichlern zeigt wie hart und eisern
das regiment der fraktionsdisziplin sein
kann
er hat mir signale geben nicht sagen wir
fünf minuten vorbereiten und dann
konnten wir mitten in der debatte auch
mit einem slot von drei oder fünf
minuten ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau
dann entsprechend unsere meinung kundtun
es kann nicht sein dass jemand bei rot
über die ampel fährt und die anderen die
strafzettel bezahlt das ist nicht meine
vorstellung von europa
wir haben gesagt es geht keiner für die
schulden eines anderen staates in diesen
währungsraum aufkommen müssen jeder muss
seinen haushalt selbst ausgleichen
und genau das rechnen wir mit dieser
schirm politik es gab ja viele die meine
bedenken geteilt haben
die danach zu mir klar du sax wenigstens
ja ich kann nicht ich brauche guten
listenplatz und kriege ich den nicht
mehr
du hast dein wahlkreis sicher und es gab
natürlich auch welche die gesagt haben
wir sind am rahden schwein ein profi
ließ sich hier zu lasten der gruppe da
muss man aushalten dass sie so
aber lammerts entscheidung hat ein
nachspiel
die fraktionsvorsitzenden und der
ältestenrat drohen dem
bundestagspräsidenten mit juristischen
konsequenzen
sie sprechen sogar über pläne das
grundgesetz zu ändern
und ich habe den dann genau so
unmissverständlich gesagt ich werde es
ganz sicher bei einer vergleichbaren
situation wieder so machen wenn ihr das
nicht ertrag müsst ihr einen anderen
präsidenten wählen bundestags juristen
bestätigen später lammertz umstrittene
entscheidung entsprach der geltenden
geschäftsordnung den parlamentarismus
betont und das ist auch im parlament
unterschiedliche auffassungen geben darf
innerhalb von fraktionen ich fand das
ziemlich gut damals
[Musik]
bereits 1965 erlebt die junge brd eine
debatte bei der die politische
farbenlehre ausdrücklich außer kraft
gesetzt ist dürfen verbrechen aus der
zeit des ns regimes weiter verfolgt
werden oder gilt die verjährungsfrist
die immerhin das grundgesetz vorsieht
dann kämen viele der einstigen täter
bald ungestraft davon
das ist die frage die hinter der
verjährung stand würde die deutsche
gesellschaft den nationalsozialismus
irgendwie entsorgen können oder würde er
sie dauerhaft begleiten bundeskanzler
ludwig erhard ohnehin keine chance das
grundgesetz zu ändern
deshalb lässt er die abgeordneten frei
von fraktionszwang sprechen so entbrennt
am 10 märz 65 eine offene diskussion
über generationen grenzen hinweg auch
abgeordnete aus der zweiten und dritten
reihe ergreifen das wort
es sollte sie hier um eine frage die
nach in erster linie nach rechtlichen
überlegungen und somit aus dem gewissen
jedes einzeln heraus entschieden und
beantwortet werden muss die
fraktionsführung waren nicht so ganz
glücklich über diese entscheidung aber
diese debatte ist eben getragen von
großen reden gerade dieser neuen
protagonisten ich denke ernst benda da
muss man dann den ich bestehe darauf zu
sagen dass dieses deutsche volk noch
kein volk von nantes und das in diesem
volk noch erlaubt sein muss ja dass es
um seiner selbst willen wissen
das ist mit diesen wörtern nicht
identifiziert wird sondern dass es von
diesen mördern befreit und dass es
besser gesagt deutlicher gesagt sich
selber von ihm befreien kann zu einer
entscheidung findet das plenum an diesem
tag nicht
es dauert noch etliche jahre bis das
parlament beschließt ns-verbrechen
müssen bestraft werden ohne jede frist
die geschichte der debatten über die
verjährung zeigt wie schwer sich die
bundesrepublik damit getan hat die
nationalsozialistische geschichte als
ihr erbe anzunehmen und wie sie sich
entwickelt hat
der streit um den paragrafen 218 bewegt
westdeutschland in den 70er jahren
sollen abtreibungen weiterhin mit
haftstrafen bedroht werden wie es das
gesetz von 1872 noch immer vorsieht eine
frage die sinnbildlich für ein häufiges
dilemma der parlamentarier steht mit
blick auf die gewissensfreiheit des
einzelnen abgeordneten ja er muss am
ende oder sie muss am ende für sich
selbst grund frei entscheiden in welchem
kontext stelle ich eine bestimmte
abstimmung und 2014 bringt das parlament
um eine frage die unheilbar kranke und
ihre angehörigen betrifft soll der staat
unterstützung beim selbstmord verbieten
oder aktive sterbehilfe sogar erlauben
zwei der heikelsten abwägungen in 70
jahren bundestags geschichte da ist es
auch vernünftig dass man nicht den
eindruck erweckt das würde hier nach
parteien entschieden sondern da muss
jeder sich auf eine besondere weise
selber noch mal befragen
und 2017 die ehe für alle auch
homosexuelle paare sollen künftig
heiraten dürfen
seit jahren fordern verbände die
gesetzliche anerkennung ihre
partnerschaften ganz plötzlich landet
die diskussion im bundestag dass merkel
die abstimmung frei gibt wie sie sagt
wird als sensation gefeiert
dabei lassen viele berichte ein
elementares abgeordneten recht völlig
außer acht
abstimmungen können und müssen nicht
freigegeben werden durch wen eigentlich
denn die verfassungslage ist völlig
unmissverständlich
die abgeordneten sind wie es in artikel
38 des grundgesetzes heißt vertreter des
ganzen volkes an aufträge und weisungen
nicht gebunden peter abgeordnete ist
frei mir muss keiner meine abstimmung
freigeben
aber normalerweise entscheiden wir nach
fraktion die debatte im hohen haus nur
vier tage später am 30 juni 2017
verläuft ohne nennenswerte konflikte die
entfesselten redner sind sich in der
sache eigentlich niemanden etwas
weggenommen niemand muss alle dürfen
es wird lediglich ein paar mehr mögliche
menschen geben vielen dank und noch
einmal gibt der bundestagspräsident dem
parlament freundlich nachhilfe für die
viel strapazierte frage was denn eine
gewissensentscheidung sei gibt es eine
einzige zuständige instanz ist der
jeweils einzelne abgeordnet werden so
wäre schön wenn das die zukunft
investieren die deutlich
in rekordzeit passiert die entscheidung
den bundestag
393 abgeordnete geben der ehe für alle
ihren segen 226 lehnen sie ab darunter
die kanzlerin am montag war das
interview am freitag war in zweiter und
dritter beratung das gesetz fertig und
die ehe für alle wörter in rund sieben
jahrzehnten bundestag hat sich mehr als
der standort und die mode geändert das
land ist größer geworden und auch das
parlament inzwischen gibt es sechs
parteien und mehr als 700 abgeordnete
aber abweichler haben immer noch einen
schweren stand
ich verstehe es einfach auch nach 46
jahren in der politik nicht warum sich
parteien so schwertun unterschiedliche
meinungen zur geltung kommen zu lassen
es ist doch kein ausnahmefall es ist
doch der regelfall in volksparteien dass
es unterschiedliche meinungen gibt der
spaß der demokratie ist der streit und
zwar mit argumenten
das macht die demokratie ist so
attraktiv
[Musik]